هجوم روسيه جديده على كيف يؤكد اتخاذ
القرار بشان موعد تحرك القوات الاوكرانيه
طرف النزاع بالسودان يتفقان على بحثه وقف
طويل الامد للنار قد يستلزم اخلاء القوات
من المناطق المهبوله
الفضاء الماهوله سينشو 16 والتي تقل اول
رائد فضاء مدني صيني
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره اخباريه من العربيه قال رئيس بلديه
سكيه هجوما روسيا جديدا استهدف باعداد
كبيره من المسيرات العاصمه الاوكرانيه
الليله الماضيه مشيرا الى ان سقوط حطام
بعضها تسبب في حرائق
ببنايات سكنيه واحتراق سيارات ذكر مسؤولون
اوكرانيون الناس سلاح الجو الاوكراني دم
اكثر من 20 طائره مسيره في الهجوم الروسي
وصف رئيس الاداره العسكريه في كييف الهجوم
بانه هائل
[موسيقى]
وسط توقعات بشان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
على رئيس الاوكراني فولدو مرزلنسكي
موافقته بشان مواعيد تحرك القوات
الاوكرانيه
بهذا الشان انه عقد اجتماعا مع قيادات
القوات المسلحه واستمع عائله تقارير
القائد العام وقاده المحاور الرئيسيه اشار
الى انه اصدر موافقته على المواعيد
المتعلقه بتحرك قواته وموافقاته على جميع
القرارات بشان الهجوم المتعاط
ى قال ايضا منصات باتريوت الامريكيه تضمن
لاوكرانيا اعتراض اي صاروخ الروسي بالنسبه
100%
عندما تؤمن منصات باتريوت الامريكيه بايدي
الاوكرانيين لاعتراض الكامله لاي صاروخ
الروسي بالنسبه 100% عندها سيهزم الارهاب
وبالطبع لا يوجد اذلال لدوله ارهابيه اكبر
من نجاحات محاربين في الواقع مع نجاحنا
وضغطنا ووجود علينا ان نستمر في الرد على
روسيا وجميع مظاهر الشر
اكد مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني في
تصريحات العربيه ان الهجوم الاوكرانيه
المضاد لا يتمثل بعمليه عسكريه واحده بل
بسلسله من العمليات الجاريه مشيرا الى ان
بعض عمليات الهجوم جاريه منذ عده اسابيع
اما فيما يخص هجومنا ولم يحصل الان فهذا
غير صحيح لان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد لا
يتمثل بعمليه عسكريه واحده في ساعه معينه
ثم نراها على شاشه التلفزيون هذه الهجمات
المضاده هي سلسله من العمليات الصغيره
والكبيره والبعض منها جاريه منذ عده
اسابيع
اعلنت المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في بيان مشترك عن توقيع
اتفاق بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لتمديد الهدنه لمده خمسه ايام
جديده وذلك لاتاحه مزيدا من الوقت للجهات
الانسانيه للقيام بعملهم الحيوي كما اتفق
الطرفان على مناقشه وقف اطلاق النار طويل
الامد قد يستلزم اخلاء القوات من المناطق
الماكوله بما في ذلك منازل المدنيين
وازاله المزيد من العوائق امام حريه تنقل
المدنيين والمساعدات الانسانيه اضافه
لتمكين الموظفين الحكوميين من استئناف
واجباتهم المعتاده
رحب المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه
بالسودان خالد عمر باتفاق الجيش والدعم
السريع على تمديد وقف اطلاق النار خمسه
ايام دعا المتحدث طرفي الصراع للالتزام
الصارم بنص اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار وتركيز
الجهود على معالجه الوضع الانساني المتزور
منظمه الامم المتحده بدورها دخلت على خط
الدعوات لاحترام الهدان الانسانيه والسماح
بايصال المساعدات قالت الامم المتحده انه
على الرغم من اتفاق الهدنه الا انها تكافح
من اجل الحصول على موافقات وضمانات امنيه
بغيه وصول المساعدات وفرق الاغاثه الى
الاماكن المحتاجه
اكاد يوسف عزه المستشار السياسي لقائد
القوات الدعم السريع بالسودان ان الايام
الخمسه المقبله ستشهد مباحثات لتلافي
اسباب فشل الهدى السابقه وللوصول الى وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار خمسه ايام القادمه هي
للنقاش حولي
السابقه للوصول الى هدنه
دائما او يمكن تطويرها لوقت دعم لاطلاق
النار هذا هو الهدف الذي تسعى له قياده
الدعم السريع وهو هذا الدعم السريع انه
يكون هنالك وقت حقيقي لاطلاق النار لان
الوقفه الحقيقه اطلاق النار
على طول يقود الى عمليه سياسيه او بدء
التفاوض سياسي ياتي باخرين ليس هم دعم
سريع ليسوا هم قوات مسلحه وهم قوه سياسيه
اطراف كثيره ستشارك في العمليه السياسيه
مجتمع مدني احزاب
كما اكد المستشار السياسي لمحمد حمدانو ان
حماتي على قيد الحياه وبصحه جيده
انه السيد الفريق اول محمد حمدان بصحه
كامله لم يصاب ليس لديه اي حاله مرضيه هو
يمارس مهامي في غايه القوات الدعم السريع
بشكل يومي انا على تواصل معه بشكل يومي
اتلقى منه اتصالات يتحدث معه اتشاور معه
في الامور السياسيه في القضايا التي انا
اسافر
للرسائل التي اسافر لتوصيلها منه لتشاور
معه في في كيفيه العمل السياسي كيفيه
ايقاف الحق هو بحاله جيده يمارس مهامي على
كل الاصغر على مستوى السياسي على مستوى
العسكري كل هذه الدعايه هي لاخراج محمد
للاعلام او هذه عمليه ليس هو
اعلان من او من الواجبات المقدمه لدي
اصحى ظهور السلاح باقليم دارفور بعد
القتال بين الجيش والدعم السريه مظهرا شبه
هادي على رغم من منعه في السابق يتخوف
سكان الاقليم من الدعوات المتكرره للتسلح
من جهات النافذه بان تفاقم من حاله
السيوله الامنيه الحاليه بدرسول
يتجول سليمان حسب الكريم بسلاحه داخل سوق
الضعين غربيه السودان في مشهد اصبح مالوفا
في مدن اقليم دارفور فمنذ اندلاع القتال
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في منتصف ابريل
الماضي عاد السلاح مره اخرى الى الزهور
بكثره في ايدي المواطنين بالاحياء
والاسواق حجتهم في ذلك حمايه انفسهم من
النهب والسلب
والله لحمايه نفسي بس وانا زلت تاجر وقاعد
في الخلا وشايل السلاح ده بس من النهب
لعدم حفظ الامن لانه ما في اسي دوله
بتحمانا من النهب والسلب عشان كذا انا
شايل السلاح حمايه نفسي وعشره دارفور في
السنوات السابقه صراعات عديده متواصله
استخدم فيها السلاح بشكل سافر مما جعل بعض
القيادات الاهليه تتخوف من تكرار ذات
الخلافات القديمه التي عاشها الاقليم بسبب
السلاح والسيوله الامنيه لذلك نحن نقول
هذه الخطوه خطوه غير موفقه ونحن نطالب
المجتمع الدولي والاخوه الوسطاء السعوديين
والمتحده ان يقفوا على هذه الحاله لان هذه
الازمه ستصبح عظمه يمكنكم تضييق على
السودانيين فيما ينادي بعض المواطنين
بالمضي قدما في عمليات جمع السلاح بدلا من
تقنين انتشاره خوفا من الانزلاق الى الحرب
الاهليه بدرفور الى ان بعض المناطق ما
زالت ساخنه نحن نرفض جمله وتفصيله لان
الاستنفار السلاح عند المواطن ذات نجمعه
نحن الان نحن مع جهه وتجمع السلاح جمع
السلاح ومحاربه الظواهر السلبه نحن الان
ما دارين كذا ما دارين كذا كل الحاجات دي
احنا الان محاربينها تماما وما دايرين اي
خلل وتقول جهات مختصه انه رغم الحملات
المتكرره فلا يزال السلاح بكافه انواعه
بحوزه سكان دارفور انقسام للمجتمع بدار 4
بين مؤيد
ورافط قاسم مشترك وحمايه الارواح
والممتلكات وتعزيز الامن والسلام
صالح ابو علامه لقناته العربيه والحدث
اقليم دارفور غربيه السودان
[موسيقى]
الاوضاع الامنيه للبلد عملت في القطاع
الصحيات طلعت من الخدمه ان احنا في منطقه
هي في مرمى النيران
كلها يعني غيار جروح اي زول عنده علاج
عنده متوفر في البيت او زايد يوديه لناس
الطوارئ احنا هنا في الراشدين شمال بنحتاج
لكل الادويه بنحتاج للاطباء ومحتاجين لاي
زوجات انه يساعدنا
[موسيقى]
نشطرها مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
في بدايه ولايته الاخيره اردوغان يواجه
تحديات الانقسام والاقتصاد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد انتهى السباق الرئاسيه
الاهم في تاريخ تركيا بفوز رجب طيب
اردوغان بولايه رئاسيه جديده لكن الوضع
الاقتصادي في البلاد يراوح مكانه الشارع
قسم بين منتهج باستمرار اردوغان في الحكم
وناقم على سياساته خصوصا فيما يتعلق منها
بتراجع القدره الشرائيه مفردات العربيه
الى اسطنبول رصدت ردود الفعل وعادت هذا
التقرير مرشح المعارضه الخاسر كمالك
لتشدار اوغلو اعتبرها عمليه انتخابيه غير
عادله تم تسخير امكانيات الدوله للفائز
الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان الرجل الذي
اثبت انه لا الانقلابات الفاشله ولا
التضخم ولا الزلزال ولا انتخابات
ديمقراطيه قادره على حرمانه من ولايه
ثالثه في حكم تركيا نسي الاتراك ازمتهم
الاقتصاديه لليله واحده
[موسيقى]
ليله غنى فيها الرئيس اردوغان مع مناصريه
عقب اعلان فوزه بخمس سنوات اخرى في السلطه
فوز تباينت بشانه اراء الشارع كما تباينت
اصوات الناخبين
انا ارى خيرا في هذه النتائج ان شاء الله
الموجود ليس تنظيما ارهابيا بالمرشح
لانتخبه الشعب لاداره الدوله الوعود التي
اطلقها الطرف الاخر كانت محفزه لنا كي لا
ننتخبهم
قبل فكره تغيير نظام الحكم نحن نريد حقوق
الاكراد وان يكون لنا الحق في ابداء الراي
لذلك دعمنا حزب الشعب الجمهوري بالعموم
انصار الحزب لم يدعمه بشكل كافي الشارع
التركي استفاق على نفس المشاكل الاقتصاديه
وغلاء المعيشه فرغم مباهات انصار اردوغان
بما قام به من دعم لمكانه ميلاده في
الخارج ومواقفه المتشدده من الارهاب يظل
العامل الاقتصادي مؤثرا على الجميع خاصه
مع تراجع الليره التركيه غداه اعلاني
نتائج الانتخابات
ليكون هناك استقرار وليتقدم تركيا الى
مكانه افضل الرجل يعمل يصنع مدافع
الطائرات الحربيه يصنع طائرات مروحيه يشق
الطرق ويبني المستشفيات انه يعمل
مساء امس كنا سعداء جدا
لابي الرغم من كل هذه الاحتفالات تبدو
فكره الوحده في هذه البلد
المستقطب ابعد من اي وقت مضى فخمسه وعشرون
مليون تركي صوتوا ضد اردوغان الذي يدخل
فترته الرئاسيه الجديده متمتعا بسلطات
واسعه غير مسبوقه كانت معكم موفده العربيه
راويه القاسم من مدينه اسطنبول التركيه
كسر الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
القاعده المعروفه بتركيا بانه من يربح
اسطنبول يربح في كامل تركيا لكن في جوله
الاعاده كما في الجوله الاولى خسر اردوغان
في اسطنبول وانقر كذلك فما هي اسباب
التراجع في المدن الكبرى تفاصيل مع
فاز الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بولايه رئاسيه
جديده لكنه خسر اسطنبول وانقره اكبر
مدينتين في تركيا وهو ما اثار السؤال حول
اسباب تراجع الرئيس في كبرى المدن التقينا
برهان مدير احد اكبر مراكز الاستطلاعات في
العاصمه انقره لمعرفه اسباب التراجع وفق
برهان فان نظام التحالفات الذي بدا العمل
به في انتخابات 2018
اثر سلبا على اصوات اردوغان في المدن
الكبرى على سبيل المثال في اسطنبول يمتلك
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الذي دعم زعيم
المعارضه
12% من الناخبين مقارنه بخمسه في المئه من
ناخب حزب الحركه القوميه الذي يدعم
اردوغان لذلك خسر اردوغان اسطنبول في سباق
الرئاسه لكنه فاز باغلبيه برلمانيه فيها
الحال ذاته ينسحب على العاصمه
تحالف المعارضه الذي يضم سته احزاب دعم
ايضا من قبل حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي بالنظر
الى طبيعه تحالف المعارضه المعروف باسم
تحالف الامه مقارنه بتحالف الشعب الذي
يتزعمه الرئيس اردوغان نرى ان قوه واصوات
تحالف المعارضه في المدن الكبرى افضل
مقارنه بتحالف الشعب هناك راي اخر يقول ان
اردوغان الرئيس القوي المنشغل باعباء
الرئاسه والسياسه الخارجيه لا يوجد من
يوازيه في حزبه بنفس القوه والقدره على
الاقناع لمخاطبه الشارع
لدى حزب العداله فريق يعمل في الدعايه
والتواصل مع الجماهير لكن يلاحظ وجود
تقاعس في بعض الاحيان وعدم وجود قدره على
الاقناع بقدر قوه الرئيس اردوغان في احيان
اخرى
وحصل اردوغان في انقره على
48.7% من الاصوات مقابل
51.2%
لمنافسه كمال كلش دارولو وهي نفس النسبه
تقريبا في اسطنبول عندما كان اردوغان
رئيسا لبلديه اسطنبول قبل اكثر من عقدين
عمدت رئيسه الوزراء حينها الى عرقله عمله
وهو ما اكسبه تعاطف سكان المدينه في عام
2019 تكرر السيناريو مع رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول اكرم اماموجلو الذي حاز تعاطفا
ايضا وجند الكثير من امكانيات البلديه
لصالح الحملات الدعائيه لمرشح المعارضه
وهذا سبب اضافي لتراجع اردوغان في المدن
الكبرى زيدان زنكلو العربيه انقره
[موسيقى]
في مقابله مع العربيه قال وزير الداخليه
اللبناني بسام الملوي ان القوى الامنيه
اللبنانيه تتابع بدقه موضوع المواطن
السعوديه المختطف في لبنان مضيفا ان
السعودي المختطف بخير وكدا انه يتم اطلاعه
سفير السعودي في بيروت على كل التطورات
بشكل فوري الموضوع تتابعه القوى الامنيه
بكل حرفيه ومهنيه
ويجري التواصل بطبيعه الحال مع السفير
السعودي مع معالي السفير وليد البخاري
لاجل متابعه الموضوع ولاجل اطلاعه على ما
يلزم من تفاصيل وعلى ما
تحصل عليه القوى الامنيه نحن علينا متابعه
الموضوع هذا موضوع لا نقبل به هذا موضوع
يمس بعلاقه لبنان بالدول العربيه الشقيقه
ونسيما بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه ان امن
وامان كافه المقيمين على الاراضي
اللبنانيه ولا سيما المواطنين
والمواطنين من من مواطني دول الخليج
العربي ومواطنين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
هم اشقاء وان امنهم وامانهم مهم جدا
للبنان ولعلاقته ولعلاقه لبنان بهذه الدول
الشقيقه
اضاف الوزير ان السلطات الامنيه رصد
التحرك هاتف المواطن السعودي المختطف في
اكثر من منطقه وشدد على سريه التحقيق الى
حين التوصل لكافه ملابسات عمليه الاختطاف
وتوعد بمحاسبه المنفذين
مات لديك او لدى
الاعلام تقول بانه تم رصد
مكالمات او رسائل هاتفيه من اكثر من منطقه
هذا يعني ان
هاتف المواطن السعودي يتنقل بين اكثر من
منطقه في بيروت وهذا يدل على
عمل معين لدى الفاعلين وهذا يستوجب على
القوى الامنيه اللبنانيه ان تكون على قدر
كبير من الحيطه ومن الحذر وان تتعامل مع
الموضوع بدقه بالغه
ينبغي لسلامه التحقيق
ولسريه التحقيق الواجبه للوصول الى نتيجه
ولسلامه المواطن السعودي طبعا وهي الاهم
ان نلتزم بحد معين من سريه التحقيق لجلاء
كافه الملابسات
[موسيقى]
مجلس النواب الليبيه بالقصف الجوي الذي
تتعرض له مدينه الزاويه غرب البلاد بواسطه
الطيران المسير مشيرا لان الهدف من هذا
القصف هو تصفيه حسابات سياسيه اشار الى ان
القصف طال منزل عضو مجلس نواب علي بوزريبه
كما انه تم دون التنسيق مع الجهات ذات
الاختصاص
افادت رويترز ان الملياردير الامريكي لون
ماسك سيزور الصين هذا الاسبوع اوضحت مصادر
لرويتر سيلتقي مسؤولين الصينيين كبار
وسيزور منشاه لشركته
في خطوه هي الاولى من نوعها ارسلت الصين
قبل قليل رائده فضاء مدني في مهمه ماهوله
الى محطه يانكونغ الفضائيه كانت المهمات
الفضائيه في الصين تقتصر على اعضاء الجيش
الصيني فقط رايده الفضاء الذي اختير لهذه
المهمه يدعى وهو استاذ في جامعه علوم الجو
الفضاء سيكون رائد الفضاء المدني مسؤولا
بشكل اساسي عن دراسه ظواهر وانظمه فضائيه
جديده
يعيش رواد الفضاء مشقات صعبه خلال الرحله
ليس فقط للجهد المبذول في المهمه انما
لشده المحظورات عليهم بسبب قوانين
الجاذبيه لاسيما الطعام فكان لابد من صنع
الغذاء في الفضاء المتابع
في فيلم رجل المريخ يزرع الرائد الفضاء
ماد دايمون البطاطا على سطح الكوكب الاحمر
يستخدم تربه وسمادا على كوكب ذي بيئه
معاديه وقليله الموارد تحول الخيال الى
واقع بعد سنوات قليله من العرض جهود ثمنها
مليون دولار امريكي تقودها وكاله ناسا
لايجاد حلول مبتكره لمعضله الطعام خارج
الارض فللحصول على الغذاء في الفضاء لابد
من صنع غذائي هناك في الفضاء
قائمه طعام الرواد محكمه بشروط معقده
ومليئه بالمحظورات لتشكل الخميره مكونا
اساسيا صالحا لتغذيه رواد الفضاء لالاف
السنين بحسب الخبراء فهي تحتوي على المواد
الغذائيه التي يحتاجها الانسان من الطعام
مثل البروتين والكربوهيدرات وباستخدامها
مع طابعه ثلاثيه الابعاد يمكن تخيل انتاج
طعام مماثل للسوشي او اللازانيا وباستخدام
لون ورائحه معينه يمكن انتاج فاكهه الموز
كما انه تم استخدام الخميره المعدله جينيا
لانتاج الخبز والمعكرونه فيما يطور مختبر
في فلوريدا نظاما حيويا لتربيه الخضروات
الطازجه والفطر ويرقات الحشرات لاستخدامها
كمغذيات دقيقه بالاضافه لجهود زراعه الخس
والملفوف
والفلفل الحار لتكون هذه الاغذيه اكثر
شهيه هذا النظام الغذائي لا يترك نفايات
في الفضاء ويعظم قدرات انتاج الغذاء خارج
الارض بحسب الخبراء يوما ما يقول العلماء
سيعيش البشر في اماكن بعيده عن كوكبنا
الامه وستكون امامهم فرصه لبدايه جديده
تبدا ربما بطعام جديد
في نهايه النشره تذكيرهم
هجوم روسي جديد على كيف وزالنسي يؤكد
اتخاذ القرار بشان موعد تحرك القوات
الاوكرانيه
طرفان نزاع بالسودان يتفقان على بحث وقف
طويل الامد النار قد يستلزم اخلاء القوات
من المناطق المهبوله
بكين تطلق سفينه الفضاء الماهوله سينشو 16
والتي تقل اول رائد فضاء مدني صيني
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات